(sentimental guitar music)
- Dear Mom.
- [Group] Thank you.
- My adopted mom, she handles every situation
you throw at her with such grace,
and she comes out of it stronger than ever.
She has the kindest heart and the most compassionate soul,
and she's just beautiful on the inside and out,
and if I could be half the woman
that she is whenever I grow up,
I've done something right with my life.
- We don't share the same skin or the same eyes.
- We don't share the same smile
or the same laugh.
- We don't share the same nose
or the same taste in most things.
- But I am
- [Group] Absolutely, 100%, unequivocally
- Who I am because of you.
- Despite my mom and I not sharing any DNA,
she passed down to me her love for animals
and the fact that we're both very allergic to all of them.
- On the outside we look like strangers
journeying this life together,
but on the inside--
- [group] I know you, mom.
- Every time you looked at me and told me that I was chosen.
- And every time that I wanted to give up
and if you still love me.
- Mom, every time that I felt unwanted
and you looked me in the eye
and said "You are mine." the more I am, mom.
- Our relationship was born from a place of loss
and that's something we will always grieve.
- And yet, through all of the uncertainty, all the meltdowns
or the times that I thought that you would quit.
- For me, because that's all kids like me have known.
- [Group] You've seen me through.
- We found each other later in life
which means we missed out on a lot of firsts.
- My mom is pretty amazing.
She was the field trip coordinator at my elementary school,
she took me to get my first prom dress
and she even went to my bachelorette party with me,
which was pretty rad.
I will always think of her as my mom.
She is my mom and she will always be my mom.
- My first missed of hers was her first steps,
her first dance recitals.
- But it's okay.
Inside we get to spend the rest of our lives
creating new firsts.
Like, our first thanksgiving together.
- Or the first time I stayed the night at your house
and felt the sense of safety.
- Or our first Christmas,
when you got me that pink fur blanket
that I still sleep with to this day.
^(clapping)
(cries of joy)
- [Group] Thank you.
- Our firsts are different than most
but it'd be our own special to me.
- You're saying "yes"
but underneath has taught me that the
hard you is the least of what makes someone a mother.
- You've taught me--
- [Group] That family's about choice.
- And out of all the people in the world,
I'm so glad that you chose me.
- We don't share a single strand of DNA,
but the presence of that wouldn't change
anything about what we have.
- [Group] You are absolutely, 100%,
unequivocally, still my mom.
- And even if I try,
I could not have dreamed of a better mother than you.
- I love you mommy! Happy Mothers Day!
(sentimental guitar music)